that's Jimmy Allen's new single this is
us featuring Noah Cyrus it's the first
new music video we've heard from the
country singer since this 2018 debut
album mercury Lane Jimmy has a lot to be
thankful for after proposing to his
girlfriend Alexis last summer the pair
just welcomed a baby girl named Naomi
Betty Allen on Sunday congratulations
guys and when Jimmy sat down with our
digital reporter Graham O'Neill in
Nashville he revealed the only birth
plan
the couple had was make sure Alexis was
safe at home and not owed on to her I
was like I don't wanna had a baby on the
road because if you haven't we stuck
there for three days to play certain
cities I think I'm not charlie steady
there you proposed to Disney boom which
I absolutely had the baby reveal at
Disney oh did you yeah
what like what is the road is like I'd
love there because I was a kid's loved
everything Disney and it's my go-to
place hums New World in casinos they
have nothing in common
but me right yeah doing the engagement
there does it go off without a hitch
you know I kind of freaked out and
forgot what I was supposed to say I
think I said the generic you know I love
you you make me a better man
hold speech ready to go are you planning
a wedding anyway she's young she's quite
old I said listen I'll be there only
thing I wanted to pick out was the venue
okay I said the colors flowers cake menu
that's all you and whatever you chose
the venue if I'm just gonna book
everything's taken care of just ready to
get it done
[Music]
even that make me want to music it has a
very magical element to it and it's not
one of the comments on it someone on
YouTube just come in saying it was so
refreshing to see you have an
african-american woman after your love
interest yes
so yeah it's not a conscious thing like
yeah you know because when they were you
know pitching the director with pitching
girls and stuff it was you know it was
the same thing you see all the time
blond hair blue eyes nothing that was
anything wrong with that but I feel
representation is so important ya know
because I feel like when you only you
know highlight a praise one thing anyone
that's not from that area it doesn't
look like that you know feels like
they're not good enough do you feel like
that's still a struggle in country music
in terms of diversity in country music
sometimes as an artist if you have a
dream to go into in general you don't
still I could look like you'd be
hesitant because you don't think you
would be accepted you will be but if you
don't see one looks like you you like
nobody really wants to be the first
person to do it all right you know so I
think it's super important that anytime
I can help kind of you know it expand
the range of what a person is supposed
to look like or where a person is
supposed to be from doing certain things
I constantly try to I try to I try to do
that yeah is that ADA in the voice of
truck yeah yeah
[Music]
you want to put it up not it's in his
mood sometimes he's all about the camera
and sometimes he just does he just says
no so I can I come one [ __ ] bag right
okay I'll do it for me how does he feel
about getting a sibling he's excited is
he so he has older brother but he's
excited to be a big fella
yeah a great stories awesome